[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aux quatre coins du monde
indiscutablement on aime sa faconde et
ses mux des faux charmants elle a la
grâce pour une des filles du midi il
n'en existe qu'une et parlant d'elle
chacun dit qu'on connaît dans tous
l'hémisphèr notre canne canne canne
canne bière et partout elle est
populaire notre canne canne canne canne
bière elle part du pieux port et sans
effort coquun de sort elle
exagère elle finit au bout de la Terre
notre canne canne canne can
bière comment vous la décrire son charmé
sans pareil joyeuse et le Séti comme un
lézard au soleil
internationale pour l'amour trondelire
elle est la capitale des marines de
l'univers on connaî dans tous
l'hémisphèr notre canne canne can canne
bière et partout elle est
populaire notre canne can canne can
bière elle part du vieux porort et sans
effort coquin de sort elle
exagère elle finit au bout de la Terre
notre canne canne canne can
bière dans un port de l'Afrique t en
cœur plein d'entrain par des Noirs
authentiques j'entendis chanter ce
refrain jus la clé du mystère par un
Sénégalais qui m' VO peu cherre que son
père était marseillais on connait dans
tous
l'hémisphèr notre canne canne canne
canne VI
et partout elle est
populaire notre canne canne canne canne
bière elle part du Vieux Port et sans
effort coquin de sort elle
exagère elle finit au bout de la
Terre notre canne canne canne canne
[Applaudissements]
dière Robert